hey guys how's it going so today is not
a cooking video at all it's actually a
lego video and I'm in my kitchen I have
no idea that's where my camera happened
to be that's where my body was that's
where the items that I'm about to show
you where as well this lighting is
terrible
the most important is what I've got
before me I've got a bunch of Lego
minifigure pieces so some of them are
just random like this right here some
guitars and violins what I'm making is
Lego minifigure versions of superwoman
Lindsey Stirling rofl nerdy nummies
Cassie Blogilates then I already have
one of myself so here I am I'm also
going to take you somewhere that I've
never taken you guys before and it's my
Lego closet it's a Lego slash tech
closet it's a disaster that's why I've
never showed it to you before it's it's
a mess
so Lily has really long hair and that's
something that LEGO Minifigures don't
really have so these are more options
this was the longest hair that I could
find this will be for a future one this
is for Joey Graceffa this is wolf for
storm it's basically a combination of
both of them
because Lily is basically a unicorn this
one actually looks more like Rose well I
might switch out these phases
[Music]
bro she's officially complete and Lily
she's done as well I'll give her this
lovely unicorn head in case she feels
like switching it out so for Lindsay I
was struggling with her because I did
not have a violin Lego I got this mixed
little bag of instruments there's a
guitar there's a violin and of course we
can't forget Luna look at Luna Luna
looks so freaking cute
oh I love her now we're gonna work on
Cassie I had ordered something specific
for hers but I'm not sure that came in
feel like we need to we need to hit the
Lego closet so let's go I just really
haven't had a chance to really organize
my life or my LEGO sets but I also have
minifigures basically just everywhere so
right now I need to search for something
that looks like Cassie hmm how using all
my minifigures is super super organized
with that kind of Illinois side
I think we might have found a winner so
Cassie had a really cool mermaid line of
her yoga activewear like I kind of think
I might want to make her a mermaid
let's continue our build oh yeah we've
gotten some things guys says weird
Lindsey go here's this think I might
give her this cool makeup and I might
give Cassie this head actually this is a
really difficult project but it's gonna
be cool since Cassie suppurative Edna's
I'm gonna give her a bicycle I feel like
I might give Lily camera I think I'm
missing some LEGO sets because I
definitely had ordered a couple other
options because I wanted to make Lily
superwoman it's so perfect and then we
don't have the hair dilemma of is it too
short so he's got me with Maddie and my
phone
we've got row with cookie and she's got
a cookie so obviously it's perfect I
think that Cassie looking dazzling as a
mermaid on her yoga mat when it's our
free drink and a bicycle we've got
Lindsay so they're violins and Luna
looking super cute and then Lily with
our camera wearing a super woman shirt
Superman but it's the same thing it's
okay don't tell anybody with uniform
pants unicorn hands unicorn tail unicorn
unicorn she's she's she's a superwoman
unicorn vlogging I think it's perfect
[Music]
seelix from
okay so the project that I was working
on it last night I am going to give the
girls their secret little present okay
I'm super excited they have those holy
crap I didn't make the bow I didn't make
[Applause]
god this is the cutest thing ever I had
- where are we - are these costume
Lindsay I had a look come on your hair
what's gonna be I don't - blue I know I
think last time I saw you I never
received a better self I of myself in my
entire life
oh here's a dog oh oh oh yeah oh it's
like really thoughtful I went I went
through it I was like order like two
separate little pieces i order like a
bunch of like Lego wigs
you already saw your best gift I've ever
received
okay and then I needed a box so I Amazon
Prime to give cards because I was like
yeah I could might a month I know
oh it's real the button is real but yeah
she goes the violent how cool is that
oh my god oh my god yeah are you quite
sure what there was supposed to be a
bicycle with yours but it wouldn't fit
okay no it didn't fit so I'll have to
give it to you another day oh okay the
basket blog is I want we got Luna
we got my violent my backups over here
this over the counter Excalibur and I'm
I'm in my - - you're here I know it's
taking my blue wig
and I've gotta me where me hanging up a
juice in my basket and my ponytail on my
goofy here we go here we go
there were hanging out we need to take
over here guys I forgot mine at home
the project was successful just a few
items just a quick trip of home turn
around
oh my god feel like you're gonna be
backpacking across Europe remember when
we went to Europe for two months and we
had way less than what we have now
oh oh good times